perhaps one of the reasons that Michelle
tractenberg became so hesitant to accept
certain roles was because some fans of
Buffy the Vampire Slayer responded so
negatively to her character critical
viewers found Dawn Summers to be
annoying but to tracton BG's credit that
might just mean that she played the role
of the annoying little sister incredibly
well still comments like that have to
hurt to this day tractenberg says that
people still tell her about how much
they dislike Dawn as she recounted to
Entertainment Weekly in 2017 I still get
comments like oh my God I think da is so
annoying I get it it's fine I rarely get
the oh she ruined the show I do get a
lot of oh she was so whiny hi were you a
teenager oh you were docel sitting in
the corner dyed and happy to be there no
there's a reason why teenagers have a
stigma and that is what Jos Sweden wrote
it may be true that Don was prone to
sulking and complaining but as
tractenberg notes she was at least a
realistic character